The 2017 big-screen adaptation of Stephen
King's novel It is a major success with critics
and audiences — due in no small part to
the way the movie incorporates the book's
most essential elements while sidestepping
some of its more controversial or uncomfortable
moments.
These are the most disturbing scenes from
It that were left behind during the long journey
to theaters.
Patrick Hockstetter's cruelest act
In the movie, Patrick Hockstetter is hardly
a central figure to the story.
He's clearly a jerk, but he's not nearly as
terrible as he was in the novel.
Patrick is an exceptionally disturbed young
man in the book, and few scenes show that
more than when he suffocates his baby brother
in his crib.
Why was this cut for the movie?
Maybe to save time and narrow the narrative
focus, or...maybe the filmmakers just had
no interest in getting quite that dark.
Patrick's death scene
In the 2017 movie, Patrick's death scene is
entirely different than the way it goes down
in the novel.
He dies in the Barrens' sewer drain while
stalking the Losers.
On paper, however, Patrick's death is a little
more disturbing.
After he and Henry find themselves alone in
the woods, Patrick makes a sexual advance
on Henry, who ends up leaving...eventually.
Left alone, Patrick is attacked by It in the
form of swarming bugs, a death that matches
his worst nightmare.
Henry Bowers' home life
In the movie, Henry Bowers' father is portrayed
as an alcoholic police officer who has no
qualms about accosting his son in front of
his friends.
But aside from the gun scene, his cruelty
is mostly hinted at.
In the book, however, Henry's home life is
a lot more messed up.
Butch Bowers is a Marine veteran who's developed
psychosis and is verbally and physically abusive
to his family, including Henry.
The only thing Henry seems to be able to do
right by his father is act upon their shared
racism against the Hanlon family.
The town blaze
The 2017 It movie handles Mike's history in
very obscure terms.
We're told his parents died in a gruesome
house fire and that he'd seen them burn, which
is why he's so haunted by the image of burnt
hands reaching out from the meat store's alley
entrance.
He's shown as the bearer of some bad news
about the town's history, courtesy of his
grandfather, but for the most part, the role
of the resident historian of the group is
given to Ben Hanscom instead.
The book goes into a lot more detail about
Mike's pain.
The notorious town fire referenced in the
movie took place at a club called the Black
Spot, and his dad was was there the night
it was burned down.
It's also Mike's dad who encourages him to
study the town's sinister history, which is
how he becomes the librarian — and the only
one to stay in Derry after the rest of the
Losers' Club leaves.
The death of Eddie Corcoran
Not only is Eddie Corcoran's story one of
the more tragic subplots in the book, but
he didn't even make it into the movie.
A student at the same school as the Losers,
Eddie's stepfather kills his little brother
with a hammer, which leaves Eddie on the run
for his life.
He ends up in the Barrens where he encounters
It, which takes the form of his recently deceased
little brother... before turning into a gill
man and decapitating Eddie.
Eddie's first encounter
Eddie Kaspbrak's first encounter with It in
the movie is relatively similar to the novel:
he passes by the creepy house on Neibolt Street
and runs into a leper, which is the culmination
of his worst fear of severe and contagious
illnesses.
In the book, however, the scene's a little
more adult.
Many readers thought Eddie's mother also stunted
his emotional and sexual maturity by demanding
that all his affection be reserved for her.
The leper doesn't make fun of his medication;
instead, he offers to perform sexual favors
in exchange for cash, suggesting that Eddie's
been taught to fear his sexuality, most likely
because of communicable diseases.
That's…a little too heavy to explore in
a single scene, so it's easy to understand
why it was ditched.
The goon squad
Henry Bowers is shown tumbling down the well
to his possible death in the 2017 movie — and
aside from Patrick, the rest of his bully
crew seems to get out of the movie without
getting hurt.
In the book, however, they're all caught by
It in the sewers after chasing the Losers.
Vic gets his head torn off by the creature,
who appears as Frankenstein's monster, and
Belch has his face ripped in half after trying
to defend Henry.
So yeah, it's all a lot more graphic in the
book.
The Ritual of Chud
The ending of It certainly simplified things
when it came to the Losers' first banishment
of the beast.
Once they rescue Beverly from her floating,
comatose state, they're fearless against the
creature.
After they manage to injure It by striking
its head, the monster slinks into the well
and the killings stop… for now.
In the book, however, there's a lot more to
it.
A whole lot.
Bill Denbrough uses an ancient technique called
the Ritual of Chud, which...takes him into
the macroverse where he encounters the universe's
creator, a giant turtle.
Named Maturin.
The turtle informs him that he can only defeat
It in a battle of wills, and Bill weakens
It enough that the Losers can make a physical
attack.
It's a much more supernatural and celestial
process than what we see onscreen, and if
It is any indication, the forthcoming sequel
may also bypass this bonkers aspect of the
story altogether.
The smoke hole
The movie also completely omitted a book scene
that would probably be regarded as insensitive
on film.
In the scene, Bill uses a Native American
smoke hole ritual in an effort to find out
more about the demon terrorizing Derry.
Bill and Richie end up staying in the hotbox
long enough to realize that It is an evil
force that's sucking the lifeblood out of
the town.
It's a realization that works just as well
with a rudimentary history lesson, but it's
a clear example of the movie avoiding unnecessary
controversy — which is pretty interesting,
since it's still a movie about kids battling
a child-eating monster.
Of course, as controversial as that would've
been, it's nothing compared to...
The sewer escape
This is probably the most infamous scene that
never made it from the book to the screen
in any version.
In the movie, the Losers have no trouble exiting
the sewer system after their battle with It.
In the book, however, they find that they
can't remember the way out.
The solution?
At Bev's own suggestion, all six of the boys
have sex with Beverly Marsh in quick succession
so they can be united again and find their
way back to the Barrens.
There's been a lot of debate about this scene
from the book — whether this is belittling,
abusive, or even empowering for Beverly.
But even Stephen King himself has since walked
back on its value to the story.
"I wasn't really thinking of the sexual aspect
of it.
The book dealt with childhood and adulthood.
Intuitively, the Losers knew they had to be
together again.
The sexual act connected childhood and adulthood.
It's another version of the glass tunnel that
connects the children's library and the adult
library.
Times have changed since I wrote that scene
and there is now more sensitivity to those
issues."
Like the 1990 TV miniseries, 2017's It basically
ignores that part of the plot, which saved
the filmmakers a lot of trouble bringinging
that problematic scene to life — not to
mention saving a lot of moviegoers from a
pretty awkward conversation once they got
home.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!